[Music]
hello everyone Perry here in Park City
with another Collider interview for you
thanks to the fine folks at Kia for
bringing us to the supper suite and
making this happen so we can talk run
sweetheart run today big congratulations
how are you all doing how are you
feeling are you ready for all the
Sundance craziness I've clearly I've
talked my way through a lot of craziness
but um I'm we're in the home stretch
we're premiering tonight I'm really
excited you should be the Egyptian is
quite the venue to be screening at so a
lot of people out there probably do not
know what the movie is just yet so I'm
gonna give this Duty to you would you
mind giving the brief synopsis sure the
run sweetheart run is about a woman who
goes on a terrible blind date has to
leave and run for her life through the
streets of Los Angeles at night what is
it that inspired that story because
there's a terrible blind date I went on
yeah there are so many what concept came
first well there's so many concepts it's
a really it's actually strange to say
that a horror film is deeply personal
but this is probably the most personal
film I've made it started with a blind
date that I went on where I was so
excited and the guy looked amazing on
paper we went back to his house it was
not amazing I ended up running out
without my shoes without my purse
without my phone and I went from ran
from the Hollywood Hills to West Los
Angeles where I was living
Oh Maya that sounds really intense I
don't mean to ask if you have any
intense experience along those lines but
have you ever been in the situation
where like a blind date or anything of
the sorts is just not where you're
expecting well have I been in I think
it's more just the idea of sort of get
going into any situation and it just
going very much leftward which i think
is a really exciting obviously
horrifying when you're actually in it
but exciting concept for a film to
explore that and see what sort of the
human what human nature does that sort
of fight flight or freeze scenario which
obviously you injected you around yeah I
ran you ran I flat flight the flight
yeah exactly run through your runs in
the title twice
yeah I've been on a blind date with a
supermodel once a Danish girl and it was
my brother who hooked us up it's not as
bad as this state that Shaun has been on
thank God and we it was actually a very
good day because I ended up with her at
her apartment and we were just about to
have a wonderful evening and then she
turned to me and she looked at me she
said I have a terrible headache
terrible headache and I got very
disappointed but I totally accept that
because I'm a decent man and not one of
those weird old sexist guys you can find
in the past so so I said okay cool
and then 12 years later or I said I was
at a dinner party and we were sitting
and talking and I'm happily married in
13 years we were sitting and talking and
then one of the girls said you know that
when you wanted you you you liked the
guy but you didn't want to go to bed
with him you would say you had a
headache and I was sitting there at that
table going like what seriously is that
like an excuse women use million times
and I was like oh okay and now I'm using
it all the time like headache allergies
I don't know something I'm allergic to
nuts can you tell me a little bit about
playing the role of Ethan in this
because you're you're a little too good
at playing villainous characters so I'm
curious what is it about Ethan that
you've never done before and of all of
the villains that you've played what who
do you find the scariest of the bunch
the one you cannot predict the scariest
thing about people is that the ones who
doesn't yell the moment you yell at
people you cannot bite so always be
afraid of the dog behind the barking dog
do you know what I mean because that's
the one that's gonna go for your throat
I would even I actually got the chance
to do both what I loved about the script
that I was so privileged to read when
Shanna send it to me i I read that
energy I read her experience I read all
the things that she knew about and you
could feel that so the character was
there was just for me to be a puppet
in her arms and and and I loved it but
you know you know when you're talking
about the Olympics and they always say
the CEO of the Olympics he always goes
like he says this has been the best
Olympics so far that's how I feel with
this film this has been the best villain
I had ever done so good feeling to have
it did the two of you ever talk about
Ethan's past like prior dates he had
been on because that's what I kept
wondering at like you can make a whole
anthology about him yeah I mean we had
talked a little bit about that I think
the most funny thing that we talked
about in the beginning was like the
romantic Ethan and like who to model
like we were talking about Hugh Grant
and Richard Gere and just like watching
the body language of those guys cuz I
think what's really special about
Palouse performance is his body language
totally changes from the beginning of
the movie to the end I mean everything
changes he's really playing two
characters but I love like the romantic
comedy version of P Liu where you just
take every roller skating on a first
date pretty man and then I'm a guy
you'll pick up on the streets or
something like that can you talk to me
about reading the script for the first
time because this is seems like an
intimidating role to me for so many
different reasons it's you know you're
running around the entire movie so
there's the physical element of it and
also it's a highly emotional performance
where I don't think you really get a
breath the second things get going yeah
that was definitely something I didn't
anticipate aside from the fact that
running was in the title twice wow this
was the fact that I think we spend like
12 hours a day just well why - lunch
break just hyperventilating which kinda
yeah it puts you in a place of you know
I'd go home and it like even my dreams
we're beginning together you know a
little bit like my body was in this
constant state of like again fight or
flight but reading the script it was a
page-turner
and I mean that I was I was in the
makeup chair on another show and I read
through it in one sitting
whilst I was having my hair and makeup
done and I was like this is
what like what a journey and then the
first time we spoke we actually
resonated in a few different areas
because you know Shauna said that you
know it's it's such a passion angry you
wrote it in like a in like a burst and
you what you would wanted your daughter
to read it and so when I read it I was
like I want my sister's to read this and
then immediately that sort of we had
that connection and sort of developing
the character from there I one thing
that I loved the way Shauna has made
Cherie this this character is that she's
really smart and it's not she doesn't do
anything for the sake of fulfilling the
horror genre so she won't just be like
oh what's behind the door let's go into
the door it's horror like it's it's it's
you know she's like I'm I'm not gonna go
into that door because guess what this
situation sucks I don't get any worse
yeah can you tell me a little bit about
picking the names for the characters
because I'm always fascinated by that
and that does come into play in the
actual story here so how did you settle
on these two names okay so I first named
um
Ethan's character Roman and my best
friend her son is Roman and she read the
script and she's like do not name this
character after my son and so I quickly
changed it to Ethan and I think there's
some what is Ethan mean eternal
something evilness I don't know not even
this that's me doing poetry right now
and then Cherie was like a name that she
is actually my cousin and no one can
pronounce it and so everybody calls her
Shari sure you know they no one
pronounces a name and I always know one
can't pronounce my name and for a long
time I didn't correct people I would
just let them call me the wrong name and
years later I would be like I can't
believe I still have to pretend like my
name is Shaina and I think it was a
self-esteem thing like why do women just
accept that their name is being
mispronounced constantly so I thought I
would give her a name that was
mispronounced and in the beginning of
the movie he calls her Cheri a lot of
people mispronounce her name and she
goes it doesn't matter but it actually
real
does matter and I feel like at the end
of the movie it does matter to her I'm
sure he isn't like she'll be like yeah
yeah yeah I can I say one thing my name
is Peter that's not an easy name either
and I was shooting this series called
Borges where I was working with Neil
Jordan and was my first international
show and I was so excited about it it
was Jeremy Irons it was the whole
shebang I was gonna sit on a horse it
was amazing and then I got introduced to
mr. Jordan or Neil Jordan and I said
hello my name is pillow anyone like yeah
sure booboo you're sitting on this one
no but it's a joke it was fun because
the next day I was just you guys excited
thing to have film premiere at the
midnight lineup and one of the things
that's really struck me about the entire
lineup is how so many people are using
the horror genre and familiar horror
formats to you know get at some other
really heavy themes and topics very
effectively so I don't want to go into
spoilers but I did want to specifically
ask you so in the movie gender plays a
big role in why Ethan's able to hunt her
throughout so I don't know if you could
loosely talk about that a little bit
without actually giving anything away
with like butch at which aspect of that
there's so many many many of them feel
free to come at them from any angle you
want where we don't give any spoilers to
our audience and I mess something up I
mean I think I could just really speak
to how personal it is for a woman I
wanted to create something that women
would really relate to that every woman
I think there is every situation in that
in this movie by being called a pet name
buy a ride by getting in a car with the
wrong person it's things that every
woman has gone through from a blind date
and every woman fears and what I hope
most is that you know people have a
really fun time watching it and they're
scared and they're laughing and it's a
wild crazy journey but at the end of it
I do hope that people think
what it was like to have a little more
empathy for what women go through just
on a daily basis feel like that was a
great answer and that would have been a
great way to end but I do have one more
thing okay good which is not the shot of
the door running into and out of the
house was that always your intention to
capture that moment that way because it
was a very interesting choice yes I mean
I was thinking of Ethan's power and I
was thinking what is the scariest power
that a protagonist can have and I
thought the scariest power protagonist
could have is if he can actually control
the camera and I thought that would be
terrifying and so I use that quite a bit
in the film thank you so much I have to
let you go you guys have a premiere to
get ready for tonight so again
congratulations thank you for being here
big thanks to everyone out there
watching this interview also thanks to
Kia for making these interviews happen
right here in Park City at the supper
sweet like and share this video before
you leave and we'll see you soon with
more coverage from the festival